[Music]
i am full steam ahead working on a true
scale of attack on titan
i realized this is the perfect idea for
an episode of what i do because the show
basically makes all the titans seem
way bigger than they actually are so i'm
gonna put them in real life to kind of
demonstrate their true scale
problem is that this is a very vfx heavy
video and as usual it takes me a while
to do all the writing and then the
editing
by the time i'm ready to do the visual
effects i don't really have that much
time and here we are in the final week
of the video schedule
i'm not confident that we can get it
done this week especially because i can
no longer accurately
guess how long it takes me to do things
uh i nose-dived off my onewheel pancaked
onto the ground
shattered my clavicle it literally looks
like it exploded the swelling has gone
down
quite a bit you can still kind of feel
the bone shards that set me behind
schedule so i'm trying to catch up now
you know i can use my hand
i can't move my arm much so if i if i
need to like type something i have to
like literally carry my hand over
and then i can type i don't know how
we're gonna get this attack on titan
video done on time because it's going to
be a really good video
but we have one week to do this and
clint has left the studio so we're down
not only one vfx rs but two vfx artists
and i know we just did this hiring video
but we haven't hired anybody yet
this video is a very cgi heavy video i'm
looking at about 20 shots
so basically i need more vfx artists for
this video you know what i'll take any
help
i'll take any help if there's a problem
jake's the guy that solves it so i'm
going to give him a call here
hey niko hey jake you heard about what
happened to ren right dude
yeah i did i talked to him so we're in a
little bit of a pickle here
we're down clint and now we're down wren
and we have a bunch of the effects we
have to do for this attack on titan
video i was wondering if you made any
progress on the uh the hiring
emails is there anybody that stands out
to you that might be able to come in and
help with this
yeah yeah actually i went through all of
them there were some pretty
damn good submissions out there and uh
yeah i've actually already hired
somebody
um so i know i didn't talk to you about
it but i figured it wouldn't be a
problem because
uh he's already here
yo yo so i heard that you needed help
with some effect shots
yes in fact we just came up with the
opening shot for the piece it's gonna
require more work but it's gonna be
worth it
all right so uh we have somebody else
coming in to help
wait did you guys already hire the
generalist
wait hey guys
where's the effects artist so jake
thinks he can uh swing it maybe it's a
chance for us to show him what we do
here
well a surprise i mean look a welcome
one
there's some pretty big vesty shoes to
fill over there
i hope that if you guys give me a chance
i can prove to you that there's
something special inside of all of us
i'd like to take that workstation over
there you give me a shot i'll do it
i'll give it back to you done i mean it
would be
nice having somebody in that spot again
feeling that chaotic energy
you know what jake i think i have a shot
for you the homer simpson shot
i think jake can do that you could do it
but first you need to prove to me that
you can
do the shot that i have in mind it just
requires like a little bit of like
compositing knowledge
a good baseline tell would be whether or
not you can do a muzzle flash
between google my years of experience in
photoshop and premiere
and me asking you guys for a little bit
of help
we can get this video done on time i
want to see a proper
muzzle flash up to the standard that
niko has come to expect from us
show me i didn't expect them to throw
this curveball but at the same time
i'm not surprised can i just start the
shot don't you think it's a waste of
time
i didn't get hired at this company by
just saying hey guys just let me in
i had to submit stuff you got to spend
time to earn time
look the easiest quickest dirtiest way
to do this is i just take a dslr get a
shot of somebody
shooting a pistol
comp in the muzzle flash quick and dirty
so we can move on through this process
legitimately i'm going to try to do this
without asking them anything
and then give them give them a shot is
this a brand new computer
oh yeah perfect because i need one right
now courtesy of puget systems obviously
it's got 3390s in it whatever that means
since i'm the least experienced
artist in the studio uh i should take
the most powerful machine
i'm not gonna lie this feels a bit i
don't want to say disrespectful
to all of the work we've put in our
whole lives to be able to sit in those
chairs
muzzle flashes are a staple of a good
vfx artist and if jake
can make this muzzle flash and make it
sweet if i can look at it and go
then that's the real test i mean i've
known for years that i could do vfx i
just
never did because no one asked me to you
know i didn't feel like it was necessary
for the business to hire myself i've
come up with something and i think that
this
has a lot of punch a lot of impact i do
not want to show it to the guys yet
because i think it's going to ruin the
impact but it's ready to take from
premiere
now into after effects all right now
let's get these layers going
matt hey hey what's up hey questions um
a lot of these
muscle flashes that i'm looking at i'm
opening them and it's like single image
pngs yeah oh is that normal
it is normal that's normal jake yeah
they're not like already video
no there's no like smoke you have to add
multiple
assets so i need to take a still images
and put them on each frame yeah
and that's where the art comes in man
that's the art that seems
very tedious it is tedious yeah why do
you think
i'm never the one doing the muzzle
fashions i always make other people do
them
i hate doing muzzle flashes
[Music]
literally watch a tutorial maybe
you brew yourself some nice green tea
thank you so much i feel like a new man
ladies and gentlemen i've just completed
my first well it wasn't just a muzzle
flash it's a whole thing
[Music]
wait he went home you don't want to see
my muzzle flashes
all right well in that case i'm going to
work on the second shot and it's going
to be even better
i gotta say there's nothing quite like
doing vfx for the first time with a
group of people who are inspired to help
you along the way
and i think another reason why it's been
so awesome is because of today's sponsor
vessi now these shoes if you guys do not
know i'm one of the best
comfortable casual footwear options out
there they're made from an incredible
dymatex material which keeps you cool in
the summer and warm in the winter
and these shoes don't just prosper well
inside okay they're also great for the
outdoors you can wear them hiking
you can get them all kinds of wet
they're 100 waterproof you can get a
muddy
dirty whatever and you can clean them
super easily you can throw them in the
washing machine if you want
wait wait wait wait prove it oh the
shoes are coming off
so that's all you do you want to keep
them clean that's all you got to do
feel the insides dry as a bone they're
incredibly stretchy they feel like
you're wearing
socks now i don't know if they help with
the vfx
or if it's just anecdotal but they're
definitely helping me along
if you haven't noticed everybody's
wearing them not only do they have a
great insole
and a well-made pad but they're
incredibly form-fitting to your foot
without
any of the stitching or folds and the
material
that sort of get in there and and
agitate your foot
none of that i just slipped them on and
i felt like i've been floating on a
cloud
so anyway i still have a little bit to
go i got to get back to work but if you
guys are interested in getting a pair of
vessies for yourself head on over to
vesey.com cord or crew or click the link
in the description and you will get
25 off your first order that's vessi.com
corridor crew
[Music]
after a day of experience i've gone back
to my regular clothes
now i'm gonna present to ren nico and
sam and the rest of the vfx team
if it's not good we can't have you on
the project
my first muzzle flash
did you have like a whole edit
[Music]
oh
wow
dude i love this dance
alright
[Applause]
thanks guys that gun show was that in
camera or did you add that
that's what vfx are wow i'm the one to
suck up to not him come on
i think the muzzle flash was solid i
gotta see it again to say for sure can
we see a frame by frame that muzzle
flash because a true muscle flash stands
up to a frame by frame
oh you got some brightening going on
yeah you got the light
ooh some smoke how fast is the smoke
moving it's going it's going
not bad yeah my only critique is the the
dark fringing around it but the motion
and everything else is good and the
sound design is also very nice
it's not the best muzzle flash let's be
honest but there's something special
here it's very wholesome
considering that you're not a visual
effects artist the fact that you're able
to pull this off in like
half a day bravo like this is this is
like not
trivial if you've never used after
effects before and you know what
i think i now have the confidence to
give you a shot from this attack on
titan video
oh yeah wow i want your help for this
video
this is a big day what was up with the
pose that was hilarious wait where did
they go
nick what nick i'm stupid i'm so sorry
where did nick go i'm sorry
the camera can't see him so uh friends
trained himself to ignore the camera
the camera the perfect camouflage
all right so the shot jake there's a
moment in this video where i'm talking
about how large
the wall from attack on titan is versus
game of thrones in a moment of rambling
i basically suggest that the colossal
titan because he's so hot
like temperature wise can literally just
like lean against the wall and melt
through it
there's that meme of homer simpson
disappearing into the hedges i thought
first what if we just cut out the head
of the colossal titan put it on homer
simpson's head as he disappears into the
hedges but then matt
found something else let's take a look
it's already been done for us a little
roto mask
key this put the ice wall in the
background he didn't put the ice wall in
the background yeah this is going to
take a combination
of all of our teachings your learned
knowledge that you now possess
[Music]
there is a little bit of a curveball
though the camera moves
the hedge is technically supposed to be
static but in the shot the hedge moves
from right to left
so you will need to either stabilize
homer simpson so that he's actually
moving
or you will move the background so that
the background is tracked to that hedge
so don't disappoint him and then create
a camera track or you might not need to
track this
create a null object start at the end of
the shot oh
okay and then set your position on you
see that little lump
at the very top of that hedge there
that's a solid point to track i know
that i kind of held my own in the
conversation and made it look like i
knew what was going on but
they've been using all these terms that
i have no idea what they mean
this little like square box called a
null object and it will slowly move
across your shot
tracked to the footage on the green
screen here
they just keep talking they just keep
using words like
null and nodal and track and mat
and paint and mask and i feel like this
would be a lot more intimidating if it
was just me
and google i'm gonna get started because
there's no time to lose i got a lot of
work to do at the end of the day there's
a certain technical side to things but
there's also just having the right
intuition just what can you execute as
an artist we'll see if jake's got it
i mean i've hired myself what if i fail
at my job now i have to fire myself
then what happens i know what it's like
to be in over your head on production
what you have to do is you have to keep
pushing through
you have to keep putting the building
blocks together for the production
and eventually things snap together i
feel like that will
happen if i just keep making steps
and i'm gonna rely on that experience to
get me through this
fred i think i have this shot i'm kind
of tracked and everything do you want to
see it
uh-huh okay oh yeah that's a winner jake
you think so yeah i mean obviously if
runs fine with it then it totally works
okay so now we need to track a face onto
this
is it tedious i'm going frame by frame
masking
foliage so i've been working on this for
about four hours
um i was able to come up with this
basically what i did here
is put in the background and then get
the right scale for homework going into
the wall
and then after i got him going into the
wall then ren said okay let's change his
skin tone so he looks like a titan
so we changed his skin tone and then i
said you know what something else is
missing here
what else can we do it would be fun to
try to put a colossal titan mouth
onto homer i had to do a ton of key
framing
in order to track the face as he goes
into the ice wall
the leaves sort of go over the face and
then eventually cover him up to his nose
then once i had the mask made it was
really coming together but i still
thought something was missing because
the jpeg that i used was not the same
style
so then peter said hey there's a cartoon
effect then matt said hey you can do a
drop shadow and create a black border
and now i think it's done and i'm super
proud of it alright so let's go show ren
cause i'm super excited
i guess i hear jake has finished the
shot all right wren
yesterday you tasked me with completing
a muzzle flash i did that i showed it to
you this morning you said hey kid
you're moving up in the world here's a
real shot uh now i
have completed it what i think is
complete and i'd like to show it to you
if you think it's ready it's going in
the video as is if you think it's bad
i mean then we should change it but i
don't think it's bad all right can i
look
yes you're ready to go yes let me yeah
that actually works really well i love
it jake this is great
he just looked sunburnt man he spent way
too much time in the sun
jake would make a good junior assistant
vfx artist
this is a very powerful shot that you
created do you see the like joy and
laughter it created after we watched it
there's it's like a whole new thing i
get that enjoyment when i produce
something and then i watch everyone
work on the set but this is a totally
different kind of enjoyment that is very
cool it goes to show you like
somebody with no knowledge in the right
environment can very quickly
learn things i think the consensus is
clear we would happily take you on the
team
but you watch the hiring video right
yeah so you know all the conditions
yeah make vfx and have fun and move out
to l.a
okay so i definitely learned more about
visual effects through this process
and i do have a greater appreciation for
it having gone through it
and i think that was kind of the point
of this journey but
i think i should probably stick to
productions out here from my little
ranch in texas
so i'm gonna do that but in the meantime
check out wren's scale of attack on
titan video which is coming out on
corridor crew
this sunday as well as the final episode
of functional filmmaking live on
corridor digital.com
hosted by our very own nick laurent all
five episodes of that show are out
and uh people have really really liked
it so we're happy for that
anyways see you guys later bye see ya
bye
bye bye bye bye bye see ya bye see you
later